it's me finally our first actual footage
of Hilary Duff in the Disney Plus
revival of Lizzie McGuire it's me okay
so it's super short but still so sweet
Disney also confirmed the revival will
premiere sometime this year so well we
don't have much footage Hilary has been
sharing all sorts of pics to Instagram
over the past few months we also got
this clip when the series announced the
return of Adam Lamberg aka Gordo wait
wait wait
vans not complete without me Gordo is
back this is what dreams are me why
don't you - to me you know we were
having a lot of fun and it's it just
feels very surreal in November Hilary's
build new info on the series - ET she
has gained a lot of confidence and she
has a really cool career and you know
she's still I think she's still gonna be
faced with challenging things we're in
middle school those challenging things
seemed funny and simple but relatable at
the time and I think now in your 30s
it's gonna be the same way but it's like
slightly heavier slightly bigger things
to deal with like she doesn't have kids
yet and she you know she there's some
surprises in the first episode that I
also don't want to give away but I think
it's really gonna be fun to go on on the
journey with her at 30 and you know it's
the same Lizzy but she's an adult and I
think for me that's a little challenging
shooting because I have that muscle
memory of that like awkward frantic kind
of teenager and so making choices ran
like they innovate she wouldn't say that
she's 30 she can't do that now like it's
it's definitely fun and a little
challenging and also so familiar at the
same time guess I'll be going now
[Applause]
animated lizzy does she have an updated
look I'm like am i giving stuff away I
don't know she's gonna she's gonna stay
the same which i think is is the right
thing to do right it's like that pink
top it's so iconic and like platform
flip-flops
yeah those like rocket dog flip-flops I
don't know if anyone knows those but
yeah she has an epic return and I'm I'm
so excited for everyone to I think she's
really gonna be a lot of the comic
relief in the show
[Music]